everyone watching this show right now is
dealing with some sort of evil in their
lives the majority of them has some sort
of crotch the smart people flock to
exercise healthy relationships building
a career around themselves
unfortunately seventeen years old I made
a split-second decision to try a drug
that was so powerful and so addictive
that I signed my life away for the next
ten years afternoon and at this time I
was a [__] psychopath dude I started
punching the [__] window with my bare
hand trying to smash the [__] window
and I opened the door and there was a
kid with a double-barrel shotgun pointed
at me like my brain said this dude is
the dude that pulls the trigger they
brought me into the emergency room they
cut a massive clot down my entire
abdomen fractured my skull I woke up in
a pool of blood with my foot right here
next to my head I'll never forget having
doctors feed tubes down my nose in my
throat while I was awake into my stomach
to suck blood out of my stomach throwing
up all over myself [__] all over the
place
shaking crying sweating I was dying dude
I [__] do it
I was probably 21 when I died to my mom
there are so many addicts out there
right now and so many people dealing
with mental health problems and
hopelessness in this world that have
lost their [__] light dude this is
all their life is ever gonna be a drug
addict living under a bridge they've
accepted it 100% and that is the reason
I wrote this [__] book because I
don't want anybody out there to accept
that that is their [__] legacy
[Music]
yeah welcome back to the true Jodi
podcasts everyone we've got mike Mayock
the day and I don't usually do youtuber
interviews anymore as you know like for
guys like us you know we've had a lot of
life fro and it can be quite like so you
started making it videos at 80 and you
became a millionaire well that's
interesting
whereas for me and you it's been a
[__] right before we've even got into
YouTube and that's why I think we get on
yeah absolutely dude I mean that's that
was one of the things I actually
struggled with when we started on
impulsive was it's like it's like
there's only so much I could talk to
people about when it comes to when it
comes to the entertainment world and
like what happens on YouTube because
it's such a bubble bro like there's so
much there's so much [__] that has
happened and that continues to happen in
the world outside of this little bubble
that we've been so graciously able to
live in and and so yeah I can completely
relate to that it's a Mariah for this
ride like like when I wrote this book
people were like oh I wonder if he's
gonna talk a lot about you know his time
would low get it or if he's gonna talk
about dating a porn star if he's gonna
talk about all this [__]
meeting this person hanging out with
that person there's two chapters on that
out of 35 chapters everything in that
book is before I don't want I don't want
to talk to people about the luxurious
[__] nobody will I don't even want to
talk about that I want to talk about how
to get out of the [__] spot you're in
right now you know what I'm saying and
there's a lot of people out there that
are that are waking up every day
suffering and that's that's who this
book is for and that's that's what I
want to talk about and I feel like when
I shouted you out in the book I feel
like that's something that you resonate
with that something Bradley Martin
resident resonates with banks Adam 22
you know what I'm saying like the I
wanted to bring all I ever wanted to do
on this [__] channel is bring the
real back to YouTube yo like that's it
that's it I want I want real [__]
people bro that have real stories and
people can relate to you know what I'm
saying yeah and when you when you said
that about me in that in the boot like
you know you put me in next to some guys
who I respect as well like they're all
good guys making grown
content which is like yeah it's so ray
you know for like well I always looked
at Joe Rogan is the guy like he is the
the one on his own and then you've got
his like the new breed coming through we
all try to like make our own version of
our own grow my own content but I really
respect the Dutton appreciate that man
yes throw you in there man we've we've
gotten a chop it up a couple times you
know once in the UK and another times on
these kind of video chats and phone
calls and stuff like that and obviously
you know it's the thing about the thing
about authenticity and and real people
is real respects and and recognizes real
immediately like I needed one minute of
your time to be like you know I [__]
with this dude and I always will you
know what I'm saying and so like we'll
always have that like I'll always be
here for [__] you need I know you're
vice versa
and and so when I was writing my
acknowledgments for the book you know I
had to shout out the people that I call
it carrying the torch so let's get right
into the [__] bro you have made a book
all about how hard life was before
YouTube and and I think that's part of
why you're so I guess when you know the
real laws of life the the trivial [__]
that we get thrown into in YouTube it
big you take it for what it is and
you're not fazed by like with me with
all the [__] I've had you know there's a
reason you and I can handle scandal so
well because it is nothing compared to
real life most people who end up
becoming serious drug users can remember
that first time where they got high as
[__] can you remember that absolutely
tiny paint it for you I could paint a
picture go for it so so it wasn't the
very first time that I tried opiates
because I was given in our country here
in America we have one pill that is
responsible for the entire epidemic okay
one brand it's almost like coca-cola was
the only soda we have a drug here called
oxycontin produced by a company called
Purdue Pharma in Stanford Connecticut
that one drug one pill is responsible
for the opiate epidemic that we're
seeing
right now it is the most powerful
painkiller of all time when I broke my
femur I broke my femur in half the
biggest bone in my body I was skiing and
I went off a jump and I landed I
fractured my skull I woke up in a pool
of blood with my foot right here next to
my head I looked over and that was the
last thing I saw was my ski boot next to
my head right here and when I got to the
hospital in Vermont
the first thing they gave me was a small
cup with a pill in it and it was a 20
milligram oxycontin and that was the
first time I had oxy and everything in
my body every pain every beginning of
anxiety that I was starting to feel
every you know little depression in my
life faded away and there was no more
pain there was no more trouble but I was
also in a traumatic event and that was
my first try of it but the first time
where I had all my senses and I was
really able to feel and understand it
was a day after my Adapter school I was
a junior in high school in Milford
Connecticut on the East Coast about 45
minutes from New York City I was with my
friend and he had already started doing
them he had this one pill and I saw
people doing pills all the time like
they would you know pop a percocet a
vicodin the lower pills and I saw him
break this pill up and he offered me a
line and I did this tiny tiny little
line it was toy it was 20 milligrams and
I sniffed it and I'd already been
smoking weed I'd already been doing that
stuff I tried it with my friends I was
you know peer pressure whatever you want
to call it and that day when I did that
first line of oxycontin I was never
gonna go back that was it it was over it
was I was weightless I had absolutely
not a single care in the world all of my
anxieties and my stresses my thoughts
about my mom and dad beating each other
up my thoughts about myself not being
good enough and myself now and all the
things that have existed in me since I
was a kid went out the window
immediately and they were completely
gone and you know there's a lot of
conversation in the world about
addiction being a disease versus being a
choice that the person makes and I like
to think that it's a little bit of both
I made a really really bad decision
that day but unfortunately I made that
decision because of other things that I
had going on in my life people people
discount the mental health of the drug
addicts mental health and drug addiction
are so intertwined that I made that
decision that day because of things that
were wrong with me and just to Mike not
not just about mental health is one word
but also life is [__] hot you know
and some aims for some people life is
really [__] hard so for the regular
guy who goes to the pub because he's had
a [__] hard day at work and he just
wants to [__] forget all of his
stresses about paying the bills and the
family and kind of put my kid through
college and all of these regular life
problems why is he getting drunk
probably because of that but for some
people they have an experience like you
did where you know life is really hard
on top of that you've got this gateway
to escape that and you and sometimes
it's so [__] hard people don't want
to come back for a very long time I
think people forget some names as well
yeah absolutely and Dre and actually Joe
Joe was talking about this on his show
yesterday on the last episode he put out
I mean it's tough like you said I mean
people are people are everyone watching
this show right now everyone watching me
and you talk to each other is dealing
with some sort of evil in their lives
they're dealing with some sort of stress
or in their lives the majority of them
or or every single one of them maybe has
some sort of crotch and left unless
they're perfect has some sort of crutch
to deal with it the smart people flock
to exercise healthy relationships work
building a career around themselves
unfortunately at 17 years old I made a
split-second decision to try a drug that
was so powerful and so addictive that I
signed my life away for the next ten
years after that and so it's it's a it's
just an unfortunate circumstance and
listen like I have no problem saying the
Attucks or or people who get hung up in
or stuck and drug addiction made a bad
choice I have no problem saying that the
problem I find is when people say that
and don't have the empathy to say and
now we need to help that [__]
person get out because because writing
people off because they made a bad
choice every single person in this
[__] world has made a bad choice
every person in the world has made a bad
choice and if that one choice took a
decade of your life away and I'm lucky
I'm I'm the luckiest of all the Attucks
bro because of where I am now and I
worked my ass off to get here but I'm so
lucky a lot of other people made one bad
choice cuz I know three four five of
them and I hear about another one every
[__] day but I knew a bunch
personally make that one bad choice and
choke to death on vomit in the backseat
of a [__] car the first time they
tried doing drugs and so yeah like
people made a bad choice they they tried
to run away from their problems they
tried to find a little bit of relief
that other people were finding around
them whatever it was but is that choice
supposed to be a death sentence
absolutely [__] not I love the way
you speak about this mate as someone
who's been affected by this sort of
thing not personally but my cousin who
was like my little brother died of an
overdose when he was 23 and I really
think it's great the way you speak and
how brutally honest opinion about this
in your book and stuff and for those who
haven't checked it out already you have
to go and get the fifth vital we've seen
how it started where did it go to spiral
from there because like we all can
imagine you take one you realize [__] me
this feels better than reality right now
but how quickly did it spiral with oxy
it's fast man because when so the way
that the epidemic happened in America
Purdue Pharma knowingly over marketed
and oversaturated the market with this
drug this is the most powerful
painkiller to ever have been created it
was supposed to originally be for
terminally terminally ill cancer
patients so that they could get out of
bed they're about to die in two weeks
they'd pop this one pill it makes him
not feel pain for the next two [__]
days yeah and it had a time-release seal
on it that was supposed to leak the
narcotics out over a short period of
time as soon as it hit the streets and
got out of that first grandmother's
cabinet whoever that patient zero was
people on the streets found a way to
take that seal
the pill and so we would stick them in
our mouths and we would suck the seal
off the pill and that would allow us to
then crush the pill and sniff it as soon
as we started doing that it coincided
perfectly with Purdue aggressively
marketing the drug and so by the time I
was 17 years old it was everywhere
my I there was a high percentage of my
graduating class in high school that was
addicted to oxycontin and heroin by the
time we were 18 years old I watched I
watched my friends every single day in
high school sniff oxys off the desks
behind books while the teacher taught
the class if we didn't have oxy to go to
school sometimes we would go for a
couple periods until we started
withdrawing so the oversaturation of the
drug once we tried it then like the
first time I tried it about two weeks
later I tried it again I'm like oh that
was fun I'll do it again at a party then
after the second time it was like a week
later then after the four time it was
like two days later and then it was a
day later and then before I knew it if I
didn't have it I couldn't go outside of
my house because I was withdrawing
because I was I was an addict and it
happened bro it happened so fast without
any signs and we looked at it just like
a pill the thing about oxycontin is it
bridge the gap between the drugs that
people experiment with and heroin we had
never seen that bridge before it didn't
exist there was all these drugs over
here and then there was heroin it
bridges the gap completely and so it
happened really fast and you know I'm
not I'm not blaming anyone else for it
at all like it was it was it was my
doing but unfortunately you know in my
in my youth I stood no chance it rolled
all over me like a wrecking ball yeah
you were a child man like [__] me can
you remember the first time anyone
actually realized that there was
something wrong with you in terms of
Mike's not not something not right there
can you remember it was my mom and my
and so I don't know if you've you know
how much you've read or how much you
know of the stories so far but my mom
has been and is an integral part and
every time I talk about it I start to
get a little emotional about it aluminum
it I don't blue Mia we all live for moms
she was the probably the first person
that spotted it but we had spotted it in
my fren
first and in school and so like it's
it's all the classic signs that the
dilated pupils you know like justjust
Mazama bees walking around my high
school you know what I'm saying it was
so clear caught that there was a problem
and unfortunately when in 2003 when I
was in high school there was no program
to deal with this [__] there was no
action Response Team for the fact that
your entire school is addicted to
opiates bro and now we have those things
and we have you know overdose
life-saving devices at all the schools
like we're told you know or twenty years
in in this epidemic now people are
starting to do thing but do things
properly but when I was in high school
we had none of that [__] dude like we
were we were the first victims of this
[__] plague it was like it was like
being in [__] Wuhan epic onset of the
corona virus no one knew [__] everybody
was like you know what the [__] people
are dying everywhere when it first
started happening they were bringing
refrigerated trucks to the hospitals to
keep the bodies in because they couldn't
keep up with the amount of people who
were dying of overdoses hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people just
dying everywhere bro and so and that's
continued to happen since then with with
heroin and then fad and all now but um I
would say probably my mom was one of the
first person people that noticed that
something was was going drastically
wrong but by that point it was too late
it was too late I'm sure that the people
around you who loved you are trying
their best to you know like I'm sure
they were screaming at use of some point
and just doing everything they could but
you know like your mother wouldn't have
been blessed with like you say that
whatever you're supposed to do in these
circumstances like she doesn't know so
what were those interruptions like can
you even remember them I mean I like the
conversations that we had like when that
when I was when she was trying to talk
me will you in denial the whole time or
did you admit that you had a problem no
I didn't know I mean I denied I mean
that's that's the classic addict
behaviors to not to deny problem and and
you know I hit it pretty well for for a
while but you know my mom had to deal
with me using drugs but also me selling
drugs and now that's another massive
part of my story and and something I
obviously
dramatically regret and drastically you
know wish didn't happen but I did what I
did to support my own addiction and she
she would catch me selling drugs cuz I
would go I would leave the house at
night to sell pills to people and we
would we would have all we would have
massive blowouts I mean I was I was
living on the streets you know for a
couple weeks at a time since I was since
I was 17 all the way until I you know
went to rehab I mean she would she'd
tried everything you know she at first
parents try to love harder and they say
oh maybe if I and they blame themselves
what did I do wrong what did I not hug
them enough did I not tell them I loved
them it was what could I have done
better and eventually they have to
understand that it's not them it's it's
the addict you know what I'm saying they
have to unfortunately take that tough
lover out and so my mom tried really
hard at first to help me help me help me
but eventually us addicts caused so much
harm to our families and loved ones that
they have to [__] and pull the plug do
they have to it's it's it's I mean
people were coming and throwing cinder
blocks through my mom's windows you know
what I'm saying like over drug beefs
over over debts or whatever right and
eventually like she had to she had to
you know let me go off and and and and
battle this on my own
but must be so helpless for her like the
work the worst feeling in the world man
the worst feeling in the world I have a
whole paragraph at the end of the book
about it's a message to the to the
families of the suffers and honestly
like that like you're one of those
people that I addressed in that story
you know in that paragraph like like
knowing someone that is or has or or or
is you know struggling with addiction or
has overdosed is one of the most
helpless feelings you could ever have in
this entire world dude like it's like
watching someone that you imagine me
dude like my dad coached all my
basketball games row like I had friends
that were I was in the gifted program in
fourth grade I was gonna be I should
have been going on to be a doctor or a
lawyer but I was one of the smartest
kids in my [__] school
I scored super high on my SATs I was
should have been that [__] kid mm-hmm
my parents raised me they did everything
perfect my sad two sisters innocent
sisters who were beautiful girls and
they had a watch as I just gave
everything away and and and and just
started walking this zombie path towards
a coffin bro so much it reminds me so
much of my cousin because uh my cousin
was a very like just like yourself very
talented very smart handsome kid like
anything he put his hands up like with
you anything he picked up he was a
master of and he [__] was younger
than me let her ride a bike before me
you know he was just that kind of kid
and I remember having the chat with him
about two years before he died and you
get you get serious like you know I'm
thinking I need a frightening money I'm
[__] you got a [__] listen to me
you know like I'm really giving him that
that deep serious [__] and you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I'm like what the
[__] am I going to do like what what
what kind of like it's just it feels
like you're banging your head against a
brick wall and when I got the call to
say it was dead I was I well the other
person on the end the phone and I'm like
drug overdose and they were like what I
went what he hasn't died in a [__]
car crash has he telling me it was a
drug overdose wasn't it I knew and it's
just like like what your family were
probably doing your brace and themselves
for the worst cuz they're just like what
the [__] do we do like there is and I'm
sure that there are things that you know
probably exist now because of all this
[__] that you've been going through but
times people just don't know what to do
[__] yeah yeah my it was the same story
I mean my mom I was probably 21 when I
died to my mom you know what I'm saying
I mean she moved she did four years five
years of grieving over my death before I
before I got clean you know what I'm
saying I mean it's it's just she would
spend the entire night and my mom at the
at the time you know fresh out of a
[__] divorce kids are gone now the
girls are gone my older sister was at
college my little sister was getting
ready to leave the house and she was
just alone dude
she was just alone every night waiting
by the phone for Milford police to call
and say yo you know we're sorry to tell
you your son's is that he overdosed on
on oxycontin or heroin or whatever and
uh she was she was ready for it she was
ready for it I think we both were I
think we both were I'd accepted that
fact as well too you know what I'm
saying that that that uh this was the
way life was gonna go and I think that's
the thing about being that long-term
addict cuz cuz you know there are some
people I think the amount of time you
spend in addiction dictates the rate of
success and and man when you get to that
five-year 7 year marker of waking up
every single day with not a single other
thing on your mind except finding a way
to not to not be sick and to not die
that day it takes a piece of your soul
it takes a piece of your soul you know
what I'm saying and and it does that to
the people watching as well it does that
to the people around you the collateral
damage that you leave behind as an
addict is is the family members is the
loved ones that watch you every single
day fade away and lose everything that
you you had you know and it's the say
it's one of the saddest things ever in
the entire world it's one of the it
truly is heartbreaking to see someone
that you grew up with 10-15 years into a
drug addiction it is a it is a tragic
tragic dude my uncle I probably
shouldn't say so I don't give a [__] but
like I've got an uncle right now a
[__] zombie like a [__] zombie I
don't even know like if if I was him I'd
rather be dead ya know it's like it's
that bad I'm like there's just no point
in this guy existing yeah I mean like
what what the [__] do you do do you like
section em do it like that
he is so brain-dead from the level of
drug use for 30 years now even if he got
clean he's never come about me he's gone
you know what I mean so my story having
been through eight years of addiction
it's crazy for
me it's mind-blowing for me to imagine
what 30 years looks like and there's and
there's people that are even beyond that
I mean when I just told you a few
minutes ago that I had started to accept
my own demise and my mother had done the
same luckily in both of us I'll speak
for myself I reserved a little bit of
[__] hope dude just a little bit of
[__] hope the entire time that I went
through my addiction I had just a little
light that was so [__] dim at the end
it was so small what was that voice
saying though what's that what was that
voice saying to you keep going keep
going keep going it's got it's gonna get
better it's gonna get better you're
gonna make it through this you're not
gonna [__] die and honestly that may
have come from all the accidents that I
got in and all the traumas where I was
laying in ICU and they were never forget
multiple times having doctors feed tubes
down my nose into my throat while I was
awake into my stomach to suck blood out
of my stomach or or having them lift my
my foot away from you know up here and
straightening it out for a snowmobile
ride down a mountain so that they could
put it in traction so they could put a
metal rod through my femur to put my leg
back together when I was when I was in
my worst days I remembered those things
and there's this there's this burning
desire in every single one of us in
those times of terror and fright and and
hopelessness that says keep [__]
going don't give up don't [__] give
up and I kept that little piece of Hope
in me through the really dark times when
I was I knew for sure that I was I was
going down that road towards the end and
that was what got me through the problem
is is that doesn't exist in every addict
there are so many addicts out there
right now and so many people dealing
with mental health problems and the
hopelessness in this world that have
lost their [__] light dude they've
accepted it 100% that this is it this is
all their life is ever gonna be a drug
addict living under a bridge
and one day they're gonna find him face
down and they're dead and that's it and
that's their legacy they've accepted
that and that is the reason I wrote this
[__] book and that's the reason why I
talk about this [__] because I don't
want anybody out there to accept that
that is their [__] legacy that I'm
not okay with that and nobody should be
okay with that
ever ever dude and so I kept going I'm
glad that was your opinion man I really
am otherwise we wouldn't you wouldn't be
here right now clearly or I wouldn't or
I would but I'd be a zombie silly you
know what I'm saying because I got
homies I've homies right now still the
kids that I wrote about in this book my
three best friends that I grew up with
that I learned how to ride bikes with
that I had my that I went to our first
dance at you know with them next to me
and our girls and we were 12 years old
and the don't the kid I went to every
Knicks game with and and he called me
haven't talked him in five years he's
you know he's in a 90-day rehab now but
and I hope it works out for him but he's
been bet for the ten years now that I
grew out of it
he's been doing the same [__] you know
what I'm saying and and it's it's
painful bro it's painful and then he's
and once again he's he's lucky as [__]
to because there's four people that I
talk about in that book that I went and
buried do you know what I'm saying and
so it's it's it's nasty [__] man but
it's it's no matter how far in you are
if you're 30 years in attic 40 years in
attic 50 years whatever it is you I need
people to keep [__] going bro and
just and find a way to crawl out of it
dude when you were taking oxycontin what
did you also take heroin as well I mean
I know they're very similar book so yeah
yeah so that's the that's the that's the
beauty of the opiate epidemic story and
I barely touched on the epidemic that
much in the book and how exactly it
happened but basically what happened is
eventually Purdue Pharma couldn't
couldn't get away from the the fact of
the matter anymore which was that they
were killing everyone that that people
were becoming drug addicts and so what
they did was they quickly removed the
drug from the market
and what do you think happens when you
have two three five ten million
oxycontin addicts in the United States
and you take their drug away they're
gonna go to the streets and they're
gonna find whatever else is gonna make
them [__] feel better not sick not
mentally ill whatever and so what
happened was in the in the mid 2010 area
or early 2000s you just saw a [__]
skyrocket of heroin use in the United
States and and everybody couldn't get
their pills anymore so they went to the
next day and and that's exactly what
happily when probably in 2006-2007 when
we couldn't we started not being able to
get pills anymore and we were all
completely addicted and completely
depending on the drugs one day I was on
the phone okay and I was begging um yell
please like I can't get anything from my
connect you got to help me and he said
well I just got some D and bridgeport
and I said what the [__] is D and he was
talking about heroin and and that was
the first time that I had heard that
heroin was starting to sneak in and
probably about a couple months after
that somebody in Bridgeport which is a
very bad inner-city area near where I
was born
offered me a line of heroin and I was
sick and I took it and that was and then
I was off to the races
did you ever inject it so this this
isn't in the book this is actually
exclusive and I don't know why I left it
out but um because I put everything in
this book there wasn't one thing that I
left out but this was left out I did
inject heroin and cocaine one time on
the same day I was sitting in my
friend's basement and he had you know
everybody was always talking about clean
needles and he had clean needles and and
honestly I don't give a [__] about life
at this point like I didn't care about
anything I think I didn't even give a
[__] if I [__] died I was so hopeless
I didn't care about anything and um I
was like alright [__] it whatever and I
always tell the story I tried it and it
was like something on my brain said if
you do this again after today it is the
same exact thing as putting a gun to
your head and pulling the [__]
trigger don't and and as I should I wish
I had said that to myself the first time
but for whatever reason my brain
y'all and people were like how was it
was a different was it better and I say
if I had done it again I would have been
off to the races and I might as well
have just I might as well have just
given up at that point so though did
that scare you scared the [__] out of me
why what was the feeling like when you
did that it was I mean there abouts on
your body did you inject this in my arm
all right yeah what was that what was
that feeling like for you it was just I
mean very I mean I don't know I reserved
this when I talked about smoking crack
years later it's basically the same
thing it's it's how do you take like
crack is how do you take cocaine and and
exponentially make it more effective
using heroin intravenously is it's
actually not the most effective way
because put it cuz rectally is probably
the most effective way but nobody's
drugs in there at all but you know
intravenous uses them is the most
effective mode of transportation for the
drug to get to your brain it goes
directly into into your bloodstream and
so it's just everything that you had
known about the drug exponentially more
effective and more hits you faster hits
you harder and is more concentrated and
for that reason that's the same reason
why it gets that much harder to break a
habit with it mmm like look at your
ability to break your habit with
something getting exponentially harder
based on how much you [__] love it if
you find something that you love so much
that's unhealthy if you find something
you love even more that's unhealthy
you're gonna have a harder time getting
away from that and I knew that was gonna
happen and I watch everyone around me
shooting up all my friends everybody had
moved to intravenous intravenous use
girls girls that were prom queens bro
like volleyball players for the for the
team and then you know they tried drugs
a couple times and they were shooting
heroin and I watched it happen all
around me and so ya tried it one time
and and I and I knew that was gonna be
that that was gonna be an end of me and
so I went back to sniffing after that
and so I sniffed everything and
absolutely destroyed my [__] nose and
by the way that might is probably part
of the reason why my voice is raspy and
everybody knows my voice
you you so you were paying for this from
drug dealing a lot of the time you know
your your obviously changed in the crew
who you are hung around with it's cool
as well we decree I'm sure that your
your circle changes it was wrong with
this and speaking of someone who's mixed
with all kinds of people in the house
what was it like at that point when your
your funding it like how how far were
you willing to go because you're a good
guy and you've got morals and you care
about people we all know this about you
now but in order to sell drugs to
someone and to see this person that
you're given the drug that you get in
the states that they're getting in you
got to cut off emotionally you got to
think selfishly were you be able to do
that how did you reason that yeah I mean
i 100% did that I was a I like to
consider myself a dealer with morals if
that makes any sense sure I wasn't in
the habit of you know beating people I
was in the habit of of beating the [__]
out of people that happened a lot of
times obviously where we had to do that
but it wasn't something that I was a was
a fan of doing and I also never wanted
to be someone who put someone on to a
drug for the first time it was a very
important thing to me and I know people
looking in will say well you know what
is that [__] [__] like you're
still scumbag and I'm willing to take
whatever abuse people you know throw at
me but there were a couple rules that I
did follow and one of them was not
giving someone their first drug I never
wanted to do that
so it was two things it was it was one
desperation that was number one I think
I think everyone has a moral compass
everyone wants to talk about how strong
their morals are but I I I as well as
I'm sure you know those when those
morals start to get tested under
pressure especially extreme pressure a
lot of people will hold in that scenario
yeah and so I think it's easy to look in
on this conversation from the outside
and say I would never [__] do that I
would never do that I would never do
that and I would never do that but those
are the people who have never been put
into a situation where they were clawing
for life and that everything or
everything was falling around them and
nail and they had no options and that's
why when I look at people who do
anything for money well
said this before whether it's only fans
whether it's I hate to say it but
[__] robbing the convenience store
I'm not saying those things are
justified but all I'm saying is it's
really hard to look in from the outside
and make judgment on people who are [__]
who are facing the evils that we don't
understand growing up in a neighborhood
and not having food to eat when you're
six years old you know what I'm saying
That's not me but people do it every day
and they go and they rob the [__]
store to get food because they're gonna
die or their families gonna [__] die
if they don't do it so I don't pass
judgment on [__] anybody bro and I'm
not saying it's okay and I'm not saying
there are other ways to do and I wish
people would find those but I also I
also like I said I don't judge people
and so when I was when I was doing that
[__] it was partially desperation but
then a weird way you think you also have
to understand is when people are coming
to me for drugs they were coming to me
throwing up [__] themselves sweating
all over the place and I got into with a
habit of making that stop and so to me I
was a miracle worker I wasn't a drug
dealer and it wasn't until I started to
understand my ways when I got older that
I understood the error and I understood
how bad what I was doing was um and and
started to feel the regret that I feel
now about the things that I've done but
at the time it was a mix of desperation
but also just know just this thought
that like you know these people are
gonna be aren't gonna be able to go to
work they're not gonna be able to
continue feeding their own kids if they
don't get high you know what I'm saying
and so I always looked at it as a way of
like making them feel better but
obviously that was the you know it
wasn't okay you know and I've come to
terms with that now yeah I mean you were
bullshitting yourself a little bit okay
yeah and I'm sure like we all do
you've been in some wild situations you
know I want you to tell people a little
bit about like how dark things got at
times because I think you know you're
very good at recounting this and that in
the you know the the epidemic and how
bad it got but I don't think people
really fully get like how dark things
get for people around you for you can
you tell me some of the sort of
how about it go yeah I mean listen if
you watch movies about stuff you can get
an idea and I think everybody's you know
watched movies about crime about gang
life about about cartels all of the
drugged world in this country is only a
couple steps removed from the [__] you
see even the whitest white kids in
[__] Greenwich Connecticut are only a
couple steps removed from being in
Queens New York with shipments of [__]
coming in it's all very tight thing and
so all of the evils that come along with
it are gruesome they're gruesome and as
you know and as I as I stepped up that
ladder towards New York City and towards
those kind of people I mean I saw
everything I saw you know my kid i sat
and watched my connect get you know
pistol-whipped in the [__] face over
and over to a point that he almost died
and I had a I had to go in and step in
and plead with the guy that was doing it
to please [__] stop and he put the
gun in my [__] face up to my teeth
and said you know I stopped so I didn't
say anything at that point I stood there
idly by and awaited my fate and I didn't
get killed obviously but I watched that
happen I've you know had ii-i've had
drug deals go wrong where I've gotten
out and I was selling [__] to this one
kid and he I told him I wanted to see
the money and he wanted to see the drugs
first so he could weigh it out and he
took the drugs and I just gave them to
him to you know look at I never would do
it but I was just so impatient that day
and he started to walk away with the
drugs and he said [__] do something
about it and I got out and I ran after
him and when I was going to throw a
punch at him my foot settled into a hole
in the driveway and his boy came over
and tackled me from the side while my
foot was locked into this hole in the
driveway and my entire I just heard and
my entire [__] foot was just hanging
off the bones were sticking through the
skin and as I was laying on the ground
which shock started and said and they
were beating the [__] [__] on him he
punched me in the face over and over and
over again and luckily my boys were
there and they helped they helped knock
them out got the drugs back we left in
the car we were on the way to the
hospital I had to stash the drugs and
all the end and we had full you know
we're on we were almost
we're almost at the hospital we're
getting onto the ramp on the highway and
I got surrounded by every narcotics
agent detective everybody from from that
department and I had to lay on the
ground face down for two hours while I
searched my car with my foot hanging off
my [__] leg and so like your body's
been unlucky bro for so many I've so
many scars on my body at her that her
massive scars but on I want to go back
to this the gun situation because I've
been in situations where people have
pulled weapons in fights and all sorts
of things like that and everyone sits
saying goes when you watch it on the
movie like this is what I would do I
would go Baba and in reality it's not
like that you you do your [__] best
but then if there's a man pulling a gun
right in your [__] mouth like you got
a lot to think about with that woman
tell me what it was like for that moment
for you what went cuz you're a smart
dude and I bet you a processing [__]
Lightspeed I was trying to listen I call
those people um I call them armchair
generals they know exactly what they
would do their general at war if
somebody pulls a gun on me I'm gonna
[__] pull my right hand I'm gonna use
I'm gonna grifter there are I've heard
that story so many [__] times from
people who have never been in front of a
gun before bro Exodia unless you are
heavily heavily tactically and
operationally trained to react in
situations where a gun is pulled on you
you are going to do I promise you the
same thing that I did which is assess
the situation to figure out how much of
a threat it really is and then react
based on what you were built to react to
do and I will tell you just to be clear
just to be clear the whole [__] world
right now is staying indoors because a
very small population of us has died
right they're all terrified sit Oh God
the you know they're all terrified let
alone nothing a gun put in their [__]
mouth and that's what makes me laugh you
know I mean like everyone's hard until
they're in that's it yeah
exactly and I like I said I've talked to
so many people that have have all these
plans but on a lot I also said through
that it depends on the person a lot of
times yeah it depends it cuz I wish that
I could say it happened to me one time
but it's happened to me a lot of [__]
times a lot of [__] time go do what's
so funny I know it's just insane no it
doesn't make sense ahead so when it
first started and I was dealing with
only white kids in my neighborhood in my
city I would walk in and there was one
time there there was a couple every
times there's one time I walked into a
basement and I opened the door and there
was a kid with a double-barrel shotgun
pointed at me pointed right at me as
soon as I walked in he knew I was coming
to sell Moxie's I was still probably 22
years old at this point and then there
was probably two or three more other
situations like that in Milford where
somebody showed me a strap it wasn't
maybe this time it wasn't pointed at me
but they showed it to me and said yo
give me all your [__] and tried to run
me I told every one of those people [__]
you pull the [__] trigger [__]
because I knew who they were and I knew
they wouldn't [__] do it even still
that was scariest [__] even still and it
was because I was already an addict and
I already didn't give a [__] so for the
normal person they wouldn't do that they
would just comply but the situations
where it started to get real was when I
was in Bridgeport or New Haven which are
the two inner cities that I'm my town
was sandwiched between and Connecticut
there they've both been top ten most
dangerous cities in the country at some
point or another very very very bad
places I'm sure you understand these
kind of neighborhoods and what they're
like when people in those places pull
guns on me it was a very different
situation the one I the one I talked
about in the book you know specifically
was the guy that came into the basement
we owed him money we owed his
organization money he only had one job
and that was to collect back debts that
was his [__] job he came a week
earlier and he told us you know you
always $10,000 we need that money next
week or whatever the amount of money was
twelve thousand who knows we need that
money next week if you don't have it and
this was to my connect I was watching
this happen I was sitting
bed and he said if you don't the money
next week I'm gonna come back and
there's gonna be a problem and we knew
what that meant
we picked up a bunch of [__] we tried to
make it happen we couldn't get the
[__] money he came back literally
seven days [__] later with the same
[__] outfit the same black coat he
the same hat the same gloves same pants
had his [__] hand in his hoodie
pocket the whole time never took his
hand out of his hoodie pocket
we see him get on the car he runs he
runs down the alleyway cuz we had
cameras my Kinect had cameras on the
outside of his house we saw him run down
the alley I go this ain't good walks in
immediately goes yo do you have the
[__] money my connect this dude I
don't even want to say his name said no
pistol-whip to the [__] face and just
started pummeling Palmer Palmer Palmer
dude with the 9-millimeter he's on the
ground bleedin and I and I stood up
there was like three other people
there's two girl two girls I stood up
and I go yell please you have to [__]
stop doing this bro you're gonna kill
him and he put the gun in my [__]
face black nine right in my [__] face
and I go I said nothing I said nothing I
just stood there like this at this point
I was probably twenty four years old and
I just stood there and I was like all
those calculations all those
calculations about what your right hands
gonna do and your left hands gonna do
what you're gonna say gone and you're
just at the wit you're just at the mercy
of somebody with a gun while you're at
the mercy of a madman with a gun you
don't I'm saying and it happened a
couple times after that in other cities
and every time you know especially the
the the other time I wrote about in the
book where it was just where it was this
drug addict running out of the house
this was in New Haven at the time and it
was this this [__] up black street
dude runs out of the house old-ass
[__] revolver with tape on the grip
I'll always remember the [__] gone
this time
and I had my connects with me in the
backseat again this time he ran up gone
out the Sunni walked out that as soon as
he walked out the door we had some girl
driving us who didn't know not to pull
too close to the car in front of her so
she pulled in right in front of right up
to the back of the car in front of her
where we parked and so we couldn't get
out we couldn't speed off she would had
to reverse first and so he walked out
with the revolver and put it straight
into the [__] window of course to me
first and said y'all run
run everything and my connects in the
backseat I was like oh they're gonna
either pull strap and shoot or they're
gonna do something make this guy stop
and they go you'll give up everything
give him [__] everything you got so
he handed over all the drugs all the
money everything he had I always
remember that dude he had a [__]
revolver you could see the [__]
bullets in the in the chamber tape on
the tape on the on the on the grip and
he had snot running down his nose and he
was [__] shaken and I said yo this
dude like my brain said this dude is the
dude that pulls the trigger this dude
will shoot all [__] four of us right
you know what I'm saying and so it's
crazy bro it comes that it comes a lot
it comes down a lot to who is the person
but I mean I would I would unless you're
trained military trained because
obviously now we've we've started to do
a lot of military training and I still
am a rookie at it but we've trained with
you know with Logan with the Navy SEALs
a little bit in Virginia and they've
taught us a ton about reaction so
somebody reaction action is always
faster than reaction and so when someone
pulls a gun if you act their ability to
shoot you needs to be so fast and it
won't be so so if you are trained to act
in that situation and you know exactly
what your plan is and you're willing to
commit to that plan then you have a
chance to fight back when somebody pulls
a gun on you but for the average Joe
dude it's it's it's a crapshoot I mean
the only thing you could really do at
that point is comply you've had a lot of
[__] near-death experiences bro I
mean not even not even just the drug
life but like you know general stuff
like you see an accident and other
things can you give me a little rundown
of some of these other death experiences
because I'm fascinated by this
so now 16 years old I was playing
basketball I was with my friends before
any of us started using drugs at all and
we were at my friend's house and I was I
loved basketball that was my thing I was
a tall guy played Center but I play
forward sometimes so I just loved
basketball and I was driving to the hole
to just to lay the ball in it but I was
driving really hard and one
my friends at the time stuck his foot
out a little bit too far to defend me
and I tripped really hard over his
[__] foot as I was jumping up to do a
layup and when I fell I fell so hard on
the ground
I got winded you know that feeling again
windy where you can't breathe there
trying to breathe that happened to me
and so I go inside and I lay I tell him
I'm like boys boys I got to go inside I
had to go lay inside for a little bit
and I went inside and I was laying on
the bed and it was a really nice like
spring day and I remember like that that
went the breeze was blowing nice and it
was just this really calm day and I was
laying on the bed and I kept feeling
myself coming in and out of
consciousness like like I was like I was
losing life like I was losing my
consciousness and when my friends came
in they afterwards like an hour or two
later they saw me and my eye was blue
I was completely blew my whole face
everything was was blue and they're like
yo you have to go to the [__]
hospital something's wrong with you so
my dad picked me up he went to the
hospital you walk in and they didn't
know what was going on and I was I was
fading in and out of consciousness like
it's there's a there's a really weird
feeling when the life is draining out of
you it's rich it's a really strange
feeling of just of just like it's almost
it's just it's his piece dude it's this
piece and it's like this really quiet
feeling of going under you know what I'm
saying and it's this and it's obviously
the scariest [__] thing in the entire
world but if you when you start to feel
it it's almost like this inner peace is
like grabbing at you right and when I
got to the hospital I was still going in
and out of consciousness and so they
started making me they started making me
drink gallons of dye this this dye stuff
and I kept drinking it drinking and I
kept they kept bring him in for x-rays
MRIs cat scans and eventually they found
out that when I had done that lay up and
fell I had obliterated my spleen
completely I'd ruptured it massive
massive internal bleeding in my stomach
I was I was bleeding out literally I
lost about 40% of my blood into my
[__] stomach and so now I'm by that
point my whole family's there and I find
out that we've got this massive issue
and I'm just like out you know I'm
laying on the bed I mean I see you I'm
going under and I remember the
doctors come in and they go one of the
nurses goes honey you're not gonna like
what we have to do right now it's it's
not gonna be fun for you but we're gonna
do it to save your life you have we have
to do it and they walked over and I saw
him with this long tube and they walked
over and they look they were like we
have to put this tube into your nose and
it's gonna go in your nose around your
membrane down your throat into your
stomach and I said I said I can't do
this you have to put me out you have to
put me under you can't do this they're
like we can't put you under you're at
risk you can't we can't do it and so
they started feeding this tube in my
nose down my throat into my stomach and
they turn the machine on and it pumped
pie after pint of blood and and violon
of my [__] stomach into a holding
tank and they just kept doing that over
and over just suck and so at the same
time the running someone else's blood
into my body because I'm bleeding out
literally like I'm just bleeding
internally horribly and so when they
finally got most of it sucked out of my
stomach they brought me into the
emergency room they cut a massive clot
down my entire abdomen they removed my
spleen and then they sewed me back up
and so for the next for the next two
weeks after that I was on intravenous
morphine and and you know all kinds of
mariette of painkillers and then I
finally went home and two weeks after
that I had what's called a it's a call
to medical relapse and so what happened
was my intestines as they were settling
into their new home without a spleen
blocking them tangled tangled upon
themselves into a knot and so I was
unable to pass food that I was eating
through to my bowels and so everything I
was eating was just collecting in my in
my intestine and so I had to go back and
the doctors told me that when I went
back that second time the scar was so
fresh still that they were able to just
open it my stomach back up with it just
they caught it right back down open me
back up went back and unraveled my
intestines and then sewed me back up
again so that was all when I was 16 by
the time I was 17 I broke my femur
skiing broke in half fractured my at the
back of my skull completely fracture
it was covered in [__] blood and and
absolutely terrible was on painkillers
again for that and then and then after
that yet just kept going I mean I've
totaled cars at 100 miles an hour I've
driven cars off cliffs into into ravines
and and woken up in in puddles you know
drenched in blood and obviously there's
pictures of that on the internet that's
in the book of meek just covered in
blood I've had that happen I you know I
oh and then obviously when they when the
kids when I when I broke my ankle my
ankle broke it completely shattered and
so I have to screw I have two plates 25
screws in my right ankle um and that's
probably my worse injury because I have
severe arthritis in that ankle now
because of all the hardware and when I
and when I got clean I gained about or
as I was getting clean at the end of my
addiction I gained about a hundred
pounds and so at one point I was
actually 300 pounds
I wanted to school cuz that's a hell of
a [__] list bro yeah and one of the
main talking points in America right now
is the police now you were clearly you
or you should have been on their [__]
radar at some point and I wanted to know
if you had any issues how that was I was
100% on the radar both in my town as
well as in the federal spotlight once
things got to its to its worst point but
yeah I mean listen I'm still a felon
right now I'm a felon narcotics you know
felon I've got III had some of the most
insane indictments that were that
honestly that I could ever even imagine
that a lot of people could ever imagine
I I had a couple a couple of narcotics
felonies and I I was able to because of
selling I was able to afford really good
lawyers luckily and and that was what
kept me out of jail but um one of my
charges were was one of the times I got
arrested was these girls it was New
Year's Eve in 2008 it was New Year's Eve
and I had this hotel room with these two
girls and my the rest of my boys and we
were all getting completely [__] up we
were doing Acts
you know they are shooting heroin it was
just it's you know crazy drug party
obviously and I had a bunch of cash on
me I probably had about like I probably
like five six grand on me and when I
woke up the next book I want to sleep
everybody else was still partying it was
it was like 5:00 in the morning at this
point and you know they're all doing
drugs and I go into the bedroom and I go
to sleep I'm like yo don't [__] the room
up I'm going to bed about an hour later
my buddy comes in he wakes me up and he
goes yo yo yo wake wake up wake up
where's your wallet and I'm like it's
right here next to me on the nightstand
and I reach over to grab it and it's not
there and my the money was in a huge wad
folded inside the wallet like closed you
could see the money if you walked into
the room and I go where the [__] are
they and he goes they're gone cuz I knew
was those [__] girls dude cuz it the
rest was just my homies like my best
friends and I go how long ago did they
leave and he goes like literally like
five minutes I go go the [__] down there
and [__] find them and so he runs
down the stairs and I run down about
thirty seconds after him this was my boy
he was like my enforcer he would like
handle all this kind of [__] that when
it would happen and he got when I get
downstairs I'm in a robe it's [__]
New Year's Day it's like 6:00 in the
morning the sun's just coming up people
are starting to go about you know
whatever day there is it's a light
traffic day obviously because it's New
Year's Day and I come down and he's
already gotten in the backseat of their
car so he's arguing with them and
they're telling him to calm down but
they didn't even see me coming out yet
and at this time I was a [__]
psychopath dude so I walked down and as
soon as I saw her car I started punching
the [__] window with my bare hand
trying to smash the [__] window punch
and punches
screaming you [__] [__] you crazy
right she goes she gets scared puts the
car in reverse and drives away and
speeds away so I get in my Jeep that I
had at the time and start chasing after
we're doing 70 miles an hour and a 35
flying up and down the street up the
street she every time we would get to a
stoplight she would put the car you know
she would she would do a u-turn and go
the other way and I would turn around
and start chasing her the other way and
eventually I got tired of the
cat-and-mouse game and when we got to a
stoplight the next time I got in front
of her before we got to
and I slammed on my brakes really hard
and she crashed into the back of my car
and my Jeep was up on the hood of her
car for a my boy and so I get out of the
car and like just try to imagine the
scene like try to imagine like what's
happening you know what I'm saying like
these girls just screaming now screaming
at the top of their [__] lungs my boy
is talking like yelling at him give us
the [__] money we're in the middle of
the main intersection in a [__] city
right and I walk up and I start smashing
on the window smashed on the window and
she rolls down the window and my boy has
this like look of terror in his eyes and
he goes oh she called the cops she
called 911 and I and I look at her phone
and 911 she's on the phone one on one so
I take her phone and I smashed it on the
[__] ground
but then I already heard the sirens they
were already coming she must have called
what we were still driving so my boys
like get out of here get out of here
I'll handle it so I go back to the hotel
and all this is in the store in the book
and there's more about it in the book
but I go back to the hotel and what
happens is we get away the cops don't
find the hotel room he gets some of the
money back he got like 600 bucks from
him they kept the rats they and they
they drove away now the cops didn't no
one heard from these girls
for three days after it happened and so
the last thing the cops had was a 911
girls that someone was trying to kill
them and the last number that they
dialed on their cell phone before 911
which was my number the cops brought me
in they questioned me they've read me my
Miranda rights which in the United
States is you have the right to remain
silent all that fun stuff and they told
me we're probably going to arrest you
down the line I said to the cops if you
do that the only thing I asked you and
I'm asking you
you know man-to-man please don't come to
my mother's house
just call me I'll show up at the police
station you could cuff me you could take
me in it's it'll be so easy and they
were like yeah I'm like sure this was
after a ton of arrests that I had
already racked up they hated me and they
were never able to put me in jail they
[__] hated me bro
four months later they showed up at my
mom's house at 1:00 in the morning the
entire [__] ten cruisers bro and
ironically I was bagging up when they
rolled up I was in my room bagging up
and I luckily was able to pull all that
[__] into my drawer cash everything put
away and so at 1:00 in the morning they
rang the doorbell to my mom's house full
force and my mom watch me get handcuffed
and taken out of her house on a 19
felony charge indictment two counts of
kidnapping or unlawful restraint which
is kidnapping in the United States one
count of strangulation felony
strangulation two counts of assault
vehicular you know every every charge
you could ever [__] imagine and I was
already on a suspended sentence at the
time and so the the likelihood that I
was going to do a a lot of [__] time
was really high for that one and luckily
about two weeks before it went to trial
because I was going to try to take it to
trial I don't know why we cuz the plea
the plea on it was horrible I was
definitely gonna do time two weeks
before we took it to trial those girls
got arrested stealing credit cards in
like five different cities and so their
entire case about how they didn't steal
it how I made this whole thing up cuz I
didn't do any I didn't do any of the
[__] they said it was all it was all fit
it was all lies but their whole thing
fell apart and I ended up pleading out
to like one count of third-degree
assault or something like that and so
that was probably like the worst the
worst run-in with the cops that ever
happened but there was it was always
happening and and and you know like to
your question I never had to deal with
any of this [__] that that people of
color or or you know of lower
socioeconomic luxuries had to deal with
my first arrest for somebody else in a
worse place probably would have put me
in jail for years yeah so you think that
you got you got favorable treatment
because of your skin color then skin
color but also
and I don't know I do believe that but I
also believe that I was I have always
been a very good talker tell me about it
I talked to my talk too much and I
talked but I talk well and so that's
been a gift I've had since the day I was
able to speak and so when it came time
to meet up for me to talk to prosecutors
or talk to a judge when I walked in and
the charges were felony this felony that
by the time I had a conversation with
him I was just a lost boy you know who
who went the wrong way but was doing
everything in his power to make it right
you know and this was gonna be the time
that I got better I know you you've had
people talking about making your life
into a movie and we say this in all
Hollywood movies where there's a
motivational story when someone hits
rock bottom there's a thing there's a
turning point what was that moment for
you there's is it - a two-part answer so
the the time period right before I got
clean was so bad that I knew 100% that I
was weeks away from death I knew it I
knew it without a shadow of a doubt cuz
I'd started smoking crack because
somebody offered it to me and I and I
just honestly I didn't care him I wasn't
sleeping for weeks shorty I wasn't
sleeping for weeks at it's like two
weeks would go by I wouldn't sleep my
blood was boiling bro I was I was I was
dying dude I [__] knew it and so a
part of it was desperation and not
wanting to die and not wanting my mom to
bury her son at [__] 25 like part of
it was that but luckily there was one
more important factor because I could
have kept going I probably could have
just died but luckily I had gotten in
enough trouble with the law that I had a
probation officer who finally pulled my
[__] card bro and I I got I got and
reassigned to her about two weeks
earlier and right when I got reassigned
where she gave me a urine test and it
came back for Ben's for benzodiazepines
heroin or opiates and cocaine the first
the first test she gave me I popped so
many dirty urines at my met at the
clinic I was at and that probation they
didn't care they're like try harder try
harder do better do better because they
can't drug addictions a weird
I can't just throw the [__] book at
you you know what I'm saying it's a
medical condition right I gave her one
dirty urine and she said Mike I just met
you I don't know you I'm gonna give you
one more chance I'll see you in two
weeks
and I said yeah sure thing two weeks
later I come in I peed in a cup for she
called me back the next day and she goes
hey Mike just want to let you know your
results came back for your test
yesterday positive for cocaine for
opiates and for xanax tomorrow you're
going to go to detox and rehab or you're
gonna come here and you're gonna
surrender to the penal system and you're
gonna do your five years tomorrow
tomorrow she called you out on your [__]
wrong and I stood there and I looked at
the phone and I go what the [__] just
happened bro I got well at first I said
there I was like I was like I went into
defense mode the test is wrong no that's
[__] I I didn't [__] do drugs I
didn't do anything and then I went into
sorrow mode and I was like listen Ellen
Ellen slow down please I'll do better
and she said see you tomorrow Mike and
she's like I do this [__] all day I
gotta go see her bro cuz Asli shoes her
name's Allen dude and she needs to know
though that she's making a difference
because for these people they're
shoveling [__] they're not getting
credit they're fighting with people they
they arguing with people like you on the
phone and they are making a difference I
am a massive difference bro and so I
will I will
I will find her I need to go back and
talk to a lot of people and I will do
that but so she said that and I was like
[__] dude I don't want to go to jail
like I'd spent like you know nights and
a couple nights and cells here and there
but I was pretty lucky that I was able
to escape without doing real-time and so
she was like you're gonna go so so the
next day I talked I was like I'm going
to detox and I went to a detox and they
said yo we might not be able to take you
because you're literally addicted to
every drug Under the Sun you would need
24-hour surveillance monitoring just to
come to this [__] detox and so they
eventually took me and I spent you know
the next week throwing up all over
myself [__]
all over the place shaking crying
sweating having every nightmare Under
the Sun about about dying and about
killing people and people killing me and
I suffered through a week of the worst
[__] anguish ever and I walked out of
that detox on the other side and and
then followed it up with a with a 30-day
rehab and that was the end of that sorry
one [__] time dude and and you know I
tried to get clean before that a bunch
of times obviously but that was the one
time that I went to detox and the one
time I went to rehab and that was and
that was it a lot of people say
addiction is a disease and I know you've
said this before and and and part of
getting over those bad addictions this
sort of replacing them with some healthy
ones is that part of what were you I
know you had wakened did you replace it
with food or how did you do that it's
just when you're an addict which I am
through and through a hundred percent
it's just it's always just a it's always
just replacing one thing with another
you're always gonna have an addiction
and yeah I gained a hundred pounds and
by the time I got out of rehab I was you
know 300 pounds I was so fat and I'll
send pictures to you so you have them
cheers man we're not gonna put them in
the video I just want to keep that the
laughs oh boy but I [__] dude I I was
a mess and at some point when I got out
I I got this desire to just be better
like I don't know where it came from but
I want it I started trying things that I
saw healthy people doing cuz this is my
favorite part of the story all the other
[__] is is is the fun stuff for the
movie the fun stuff to listen to the
[__] people want to hear on a podcast
whether or not they have addiction or or
mental health they just like to listen
to the crazy stories my favorite part of
the story is talking about how I got out
because that's the [__] I want other
people to hear and one of the aspects of
getting out was I started to try healthy
things that I saw other healthy people
doing so y'all just tried out this
[__] got the hottest girlfriend
and I'm maybe I saw him on Facebook or
something ha like what does he eat well
he said Ali's is chicken and rice I eat
Wendy's for breakfast
Dunkin Donuts for you know snack
McDonald's for lunch everyday Duchess
for dick all I ate was fast food four
times a day Jordi four times a [__]
date how long did it take though between
the rhihub on like blowing up in way
like four you have that thought dies
maybe I should just try different well
listen first dude it's all about staying
clean I mean at first for the first like
you know four or five months after you
get out of rehab or after you stop doing
drugs you're the only thing you do all
day is try to stay clean you know what
I'm saying and and that's the top and
that's the tough thing so I'm not
worried about that kind of [__] at first
like Logan always says the most powerful
force or one of the most powerful force
in the world is momentum and as you
start to get this clear mind and as you
start to get some clarity back and you
start to be able to process [__] again
and become a human again you start to
have desires for the other things humans
have you know what I'm saying it and
when I when I when I got Queen and I had
five months clean I looked around me I
had nothing bro I was I was twenty I was
26 years old I had no credit I had no
car I had no education I had no friends
because all my friends were using drugs
I couldn't talk to him
I had nothing dude I had nothing at all
and I was so confused and so like yo
what the [__] am I gonna do not what you
were saying there really resonates with
me because I feel like a lot of us fail
in life because we're trying to kill too
many birds with one stone
and you know even two birds one stone
seen as a success so for me personally
in my in my life for the last year it's
been like managing my finances doing bad
business and being a bad businessman
like that's been as well as a you know
handling some mental [__] up and
like about a year ago I told you yeah
and and lately my brains been going oh
well you can do this as well and you can
do that as well and I'm like [__] like
yeah I can but a year ago that would
have felt impossible yeah yeah but like
what you were saying at some point your
brain go
now you've got this you can take on a
little more b-but the kind of you just
have to let that happen and sometimes I
think people fail whether it be trying
to save money being on a diet trying to
get off drugs whatever it is by having
too many things to worry about at one
time and we [__] ourselves before we
even get started that's so that's so
true I mean it's it's it's a hundred
percent accurate I think if you look at
people at the top of the success ladder
and at the top of the world and you look
at them as as like examples of what you
could do if you're gonna succeed
you're looking in the wrong place yeah I
when I first got clean when I first got
out of rehab and and you can use that
example for people who just got clean or
people who just got over a breakup
whatever it is like these these examples
all work together all I had to think
about it first was getting clean that
was it if I tried to tackle getting
clean getting my getting my weight down
finding a job building credit finding a
house finding a lover that the whole
house would have fallen down again I
would have been back to a narrowing
again and it's so important that people
find a way to prioritize the most
important thing work on that and then
layer in the next thing after what one
thing at a time sort of thing cuz like
when you look at a foot in you know the
rock and we compare ourselves to like
these mega stars it's like bro they've
got 50 [__] people working for them
on their life making it as simple and as
easy as [__] impossible like don't
compare yourself to these guys you have
to have to approach everything slowly
and in layers I mean I at first it was
just getting clean and then I started
and then I saw people were eating right
and so I started to eat a little bit
better and then when I started to eat a
little bit better I started to lose a
little bit of weight and then when I
started to lose a little bit away I was
like yo I should try and like exercising
again since it's been ten years since
I've done any [__] kind of exercise
and I found this old bike in the garage
this old Schwinn bike and on days my mom
couldn't bring me to NA meetings I would
ride the bike to NA meetings and I
started to get into this habit of riding
this bike and I really liked the way
that it felt it felt like I was I would
I know I don't recommend this because
it's not super safe but I would listen
to music while I rode my bike and I
would listen to Mac Miller and all these
different artists and like I felt free
when I was out on the bike and I started
to really love it and so when I first
started I was riding two three miles a
day but by the end of it I started
riding a hundred mile [__] rides dude
and all of it just started slowly and
then and then grew you know what I'm
saying and so I think your point about
tackling the biggest issue first and
then slowly layering in everything and
just getting a little bit better at a
time it's probably one of the most
important things you could tell anybody
in the [__] world do because do what
you can handle
that's it that's it do it at first
you're gonna you're gonna have to crawl
before you walk you know what I'm saying
and I went through all of that like it's
not perfect at first it's it's like
learning how to do everything over again
you know I want to jump a little bit to
a happier time for you now because we
we've all met you as one of the horse of
impulsive you know a [__] good
podcast you know it's done really well
in America it's like I feel like we're
your brother podcasts from over here you
know I love a lot of people if they
don't know you guys met through work you
got you were working at this [__] big
beanbag store log and calls up he's won
the [__] beep out you're like yeah
sure no problem
Logan's like and your phones and all of
us and this thread ship comes out of
Norway and and I'm not saying you would
never have found your way onto YouTube
at somebody because I think some people
are just destined to create content or
creative people and you're one of those
people but you met him at a really
interesting time and you met him around
the time of the Tokyo you know all the
suicide for us all of that stuff where
he was probably rock-bottom himself yeah
so you come in with experience of being
at rock-bottom and you get this kid who
isn't at the same rock-bottom by any
means but you know I think this few
people I think in terms of YouTube with
that maybe the most hey youtubers ever
got ever oh yeah so so it's not the same
as being a drug addict who's almost
dying but it's [__] hard regardless
yeah and and I was one of the people who
was set as saying some [__] about him at
the time so what about that what was
that like being around him at that
moment tell us from behind the scenes
how he was hard because he gives a very
you know we all tell our story in a
certain way and we get used to saying
over and over again but you were there
for that real [__] I want to know about
what that there's a little bit about it
in the book but listen like for people
who don't know Logan Paul and maverick
are are this is an organization
this isn't like like this isn't like a
like even like dobrik and some of these
other massive massive creators like this
kid this kid is surrounded by some of
the brightest business minds and some of
the most eager and and and influential
people in the business world in the
content world like this was the the
[__] breadwinner so many people had
put their bets in on this [__] kid
dude year one maverick clothing 35
million dollars in [__] sales no
signs of slowing down like this was that
the the VCS were lining up like people
were ready to put money and people were
hedging we're making those bets and so I
think a lot of people see this you know
chachi kid with a camera but I mean this
kid was at the top of the [__] world
like he had the rock he had [__]
Kevin Hart everybody was friends of them
like he was crushing it dude and he was
doing it on the business side as well
because no one had done clothing yet
people had tried it but no one had done
clothing yet he was the first one that
make a [__] clothing brand and and
sell millions and millions and millions
of dollars worth when Tokyo happened a
hundred people watched
everything [__] burn bro from his
parents to the investors to all his
management to all the people that were
watching to himself to his friends and
what what happened after Tokyo and for
about six months to a year after that
was one of the most aggressive vicious
manipulative backstabbing infighting
periods of an organization that I've
ever seen in my life
and I've been through some drug
organizations and some really really
top-level Corp corporate environments
people don't realize what you choose
like behind the scenes it's is it's not
what you see on the combat say it's not
except for I hope with people like us
where I give you a nothing then you do
you know what I'm saying so it is good
but it was nasty bro
and you know you had you had you know
old you know CEO versus dad versus mom
versus me versus Logan and and this
person's in load and there's
girlfriend's involved it was a [__]
mess and you had this person telling
Logan one thing and then coming and
telling me something else and every
there are so much infighting as you
watched this 50 million dollar machine
that was supposed to put kids through
college and by everybody AMG Mercedes
and houses in the hills [__] collapse
around everyone and I had already become
pretty good friends with Logan we were
we were we were pretty pretty tight and
he had already looked at me as an
advisor and as a as a confidant and as a
friend but that was the time that that
set our relationship in concrete in rock
bro because when everything else fell
and every single person or all the
people that are no longer with us and
and and and you know we've done a lot of
restructuring obviously but when
everyone that he needed in his life at
the time was making grabs for power and
for money and for chess moves to put
other people down I was sitting there
saying I want nothing I want nothing I
don't want [__] I don't want I don't
want a [__] tag on Instagram I
there was one day where after Tokyo
happened I flipped out and I said yo
this team this business needs a review
process I know 1 million dollar annual
businesses that have every single piece
of [__] content they make reviewed by
a five person team if you had done the
right [__] thing Tokyo never would
have happened that [__] would have been
reviewed by the lawyers or the legal
team or the review team the PR team and
killed immediately but because you let
the power rest in the hands of a 22 year
old 23 year old now we got a [__]
problem
put a review team in place one month or
whatever it was after that I was sitting
on the tarmac I'm about to leave JFK to
come back here and I got if I look on
[__] Google and the kid tased the
[__] rat and he's got no money and
now he's demonetised he's got no [__]
brand deals he's got no I got a question
about Logan though
do you think that there was a little bit
of him they thought there's gonna be
some backlash there's gonna be some
people who love me and I'll take it take
it both for what it is or do you think
he was clueless about what was coming
out or now this was this was Logan he
didn't give a [__] he didn't care he was
he was pissed off that he got the
backlash on on video one and now he was
gonna say [__] you I'm gonna do whatever
I [__] want dude
he's still he still hadn't learned it
wasn't until he took the step away after
the rat and got humbled big time hey man
if you keep this up all this [__] goes
away all this [__] goes away all of it
the cars the money the fame all of it as
much as you want to believe that you're
running the show you report to someone
else no matter how big we get me you
Logan anybody Susan like Joe ski is our
[__] boss bro whatever [__] last
name is Susan at YouTube that's our boss
and so he he needed he was the
invincible 23 year old that wanted to
say [__] you and it wasn't until after
that happened and until he spent the
next year
away and learning the box obviously and
and and spending hours and hours and
hours with people who wanted to make him
a better person and looking within
himself to see what he was doing wrong
then he became the Logan Paul that you
know today which is a which is the
[__] man bro I've got a couple more
questions unlock and I don't want to go
on and on and on about because this is
about you but a lot of people love to
get your perspective on Logan because
you get a different side of him than
everyone else and I heard you mentioned
something in a recent podcast about how
early on
Logan's someone in Logans family wasn't
that keen on you and I genuinely don't
know the [__] this was and Logan was
ready to defend you to a point where he
was ready to throw down our I think we
can all guess who were probably good but
but I want to know about this because
this is fascinating [__] the fact that
he is willing to defend you like that is
it's powerful there's this infamous
night we don't really talk about it a
lot but we mention it on the podcast all
the time there's this infamous night
this was right in the middle of the
Tokyo fighting it was right in the
middle of all of that in fighting about
who was gonna be the next this who was
gonna be the next step and that one
point Logan had even asked me yo do you
want to do you want to be the CEO and
the leader of this organization you have
background you have corporate experience
I trust you I know you'll do the right
thing for me do you want to lead this
ship and I said to him I don't believe
that I have the experience and the
wherewithal and the knowledge to be that
person like that would have made me a
[__] ton of [__] I would have made a lot
of [__] money a lot of money or off
both of those fights I would have took a
percent like I said that's That's not me
unfortunately as bad as I wish it could
be there was massive infighting and and
manipulation around who was gonna be the
leader the new leader of the camp and
who was gonna do this and who's gonna do
that and it led to this sit down in the
garage of his house where there was
about 15 people and it turned into this
it turned into this this witch hunt that
was fact less and baseless and made
attacks on my character that Logan knew
were not true and that Evan knew were
not true because I was so
let this the fact that he was willing to
give you that job people were starting
to sense that Logan and I were getting
very close in both the business the
friendship the advice Department
everywhere why is that a problem though
if you are someone on the team or that's
around the team that stands to benefit
off of leading Logan in a direction that
he shouldn't be going when the guy comes
in that tells Logan not to go in that
direction he's a [__] threat a
massive threat and so there were a
couple people who had started to create
a massive problem at the top of the
organization that then trickled down and
led to this one fateful meeting where it
got hotter than I could ever tell you
and and there was a lot of people and it
turned into this massive accusation and
manipulation fast what was the worst
thing anyone said about Utah give me an
example there that that I'm a drug that
I'm a drug addict that I'm a risk to the
camp that I'm a criminal
that was this old one person or was this
multiple people it was there was a
couple people and and and and and you
know most most of them are no longer a
part of the organization there's a
couple that are gone maybe those people
didn't know me yet because they're
because they're people also that were
part of that meeting who weren't exactly
coming to my defense that know me now
and I'm very good friends with and so
the the lesson that came out of that
night was don't pass a very important
judgment on someone until you get the
chance to know them I think that is such
a overlooked statement in the influencer
world and in this industry that we live
in where people watch us talk and they
watch us on videos for two minutes or
five minutes or ten minutes depending on
the length of our vlogs our podcast and
they make these judgments about who we
are as people or about our lives and so
you saw that happen in a microcosm
during this meeting and it led to this
really really dramatic moment where I
was face-to-face with someone that was
about to turn into a fight and Logan
jumped in and
basically said you know you're not gonna
do this to my [__] friend was that
Jake poll I've gotta ask these questions
omit you know what it's like I mean
listen I try to stay out of the drama
bro you know what I'm saying but I mean
listen like means me and Jake have had a
really you know storied relationship
it's been it's been really tricky it's
not because he's this brother and they
got obviously they love each other
but then you're coming along and you
naturally click with Logan is there any
of that which is a little bit like he's
my brother not yours or is it just
competitive I don't know any of that
[__] Jake is still growing and
maturing I think we can see though in
his Instagram yeah yeah he's still
figuring it out also as a person Jake is
much more likely to conflict than Logan
is he's abrasive as a result of that of
his build of the way he that the way
that he is this fiery always on fighting
kind of person he's going to have those
clashes with a lot of people not just me
and he has we've seen it in the past
whether it be you know rice gum whether
it be banks whether it be Logan whoever
we've seen those clashes happen but I
think you're spot on when when you say
you know is there this fear of somebody
else coming into the family like listen
like I'm low I'm Logan's brother dude I
got Mogens [__] brother dude
literally like his mom is like another
mom to me like we're best [__]
friends and so I can't you know I can't
speak for him I can't I can't speak for
Jake and explain why me and him have had
you know the troubles that we've had in
the past the the the the thing that has
upset me about it I have constantly
tried to even though I've sometimes had
little beef somewhere I've said [__] on
shows or whatever in content behind the
scenes I've always tried to go out of my
way
to help him constantly constantly yelled
what advice do you need like what's
going
your relationship do you want to talk to
my girlfriend do you want to like what
do you what can we do to help you get to
where I've had our 2/3 our conversations
with them where's your where's your head
out with him no they're not because
obviously this was a while ago and the
kid is growing what do you think about
know I've endless patience for people do
die I said you know in an interview last
week that there's only so many chances
that like you give people before you
just get tired to pull in that [__]
knife out of your back you know what I'm
saying or or your your front whatever um
but in all honesty dude like I'll always
I'll always be there for that kid I I
see more of
I see way way more of myself in Jake
than I do in Logan way more in myself
bro he's he's a [__] you know as far
as his mentality he's a fiery kid who
unfortunately a lot of times doesn't
look at the big picture and I was the
same way I was the same way and um I
don't know what it is I don't I don't
know what it is and why you know me and
him having you know been able to get to
a point where we're consistently on good
terms
um but but it will happen it will happen
IIIi truly do love the kid I truly do
care about him a lot you know it's who
knows what the reasoning is and honestly
like this is the most I've talked about
it and probably most I want to really
talk about it but um I think I think you
know give it give it time and and we're
good right now like if I see him we DAP
each other up um he's the co-host of a
show that is on MTV like we're good it's
just a matter of just you know creating
a I need to I think I need to do a
better job of understanding what the
[__] is going on you know what I'm
saying because like I don't have any
feelings towards him I have no negative
feelings towards him there's just always
been a little bit of like uneasiness on
his part and I think maybe it does come
down to the fact that yo like you're not
you're not my brother's brother so why
are you how and why have you turned into
that you know what I'm saying
I'm almost [__] love talking to you
cuz it's like after 11:00 here and where
I'm going strong listen to me Jory I'm
doing this for you that's it all my
other interviews have been 15 minutes so
when they ask me about bugs when they
asked me about Jake Paul I said I love
Jake Paul next question
but um and a lot men okay guys time it's
time to talk about the women so I'm an
avid watcher of porn just as yourself me
I'm not even gonna get this isn't about
Lana
you've been [__] multiple porn stars
like quite a few several oh so it's
funny because it's late in the UK as
we're doing this right now and it's
quite early I'm having a whiskey I'm
feeling great am I talking about porn so
tell me right you're sitting there
watching it watching a girl on porn for
four months maybe even years and then
all of a sudden she's in bed with you
and it's like [__] like now I get there
like have the real deal like a lot of us
feel pressure let a Lordan but when
we've seen a girl you know acrobatic
doing all sorts of wild [__] howdy out
it what was up for you
damn it's this is such a loaded question
bro oh listen like the first the first
girl I met in well I met a couple in the
space like earlier when I first started
coming in names name was I well the
first girl I met was Riley and obviously
like she's she's the Oh at the time I
thought she was the hi the biggest porn
star I was never gonna meet I was like
yawn that Riley read holy [__] [__]
and the first thing you realize about
these girls is all the [__] you've seen
on videos doesn't change the fact that
when you meet them they're normal
[__] people bro they're just normal
they're just normal girls like when you
meet them you you have this like this
you don't know really what to expect but
they're like kidding you the person
that's watched 50 Riley read videos
expects you're gonna walk in you're
gonna go to shake her hand but you're
gonna shake over her head cuz she's
already gonna be on her knees sucking
your dick you know what I'm saying like
you don't know what you don't know what
to expect are they like that in real
life what do they like and then you meet
them they're just regular regular girls
bro like these girls could all have
office jobs you would never know in a
million years this
they do for work and so once you remove
the idea that every second is gonna turn
into a [__] interracial gangbang
just normal you just with a normal girl
like Nava I know you're saying it's like
they're real people that they're not
like any other different girls not like
most of the time but obviously there's
an element to them that ain't normal
you know what I mean and that's a good
thing I'm not having a go at that we
celebrate that on the true Jordi you
choose all right so so let's talk about
the what some of these times where
you've been getting down to over these
porn star girls was there any moment
where you're like [__] I better bring
that a plus plus game yeah honey always
like I'm not gonna lie I've been open
about performance enhancers brought
never shied against those things I don't
get what cuz listen when I first I loved
them when I first started when I first
started [__] with girls in LA and
that was when I first started doing
these because by the way like between
you and me since no one else is
listening it wasn't always one girl it
wasn't always two girls it wasn't always
three girls you know what I'm saying
like I mean I because there is a point
where they do turn the switch and they
do turn into the girl you've seen the
videos of you know what I'm saying and I
bet in those scenarios where it's me
verse for me verse five like it's
happened with girls you [__] know and
it's not even something I normally talk
about both since we're having this
conversation when I first started doing
that [__] I was still drinking I was
still going on partying and so a lot of
these times I would come home and I
would be like kind of to be honest I was
still getting [__] up and I'd be
[__] up but I'd be like y'all I need
to pop a blue shoe or some pillow right
now cuz I'm [__] up I'm not gonna be
able to do this I got whiskey dick you
know what I'm saying I gotta [__] and so
yo so like that's that that helps you
know if you're in that shape but
normally like here's the thing just like
every other girl
they are going to unless they're the
very strange breed of pornstar and I can
name a couple names and and speak for
them most of these girls are going to
enjoy sex with someone that they've
created some sort of chemistry with just
like every other girl on earth and so no
matter what any of them say and all any
preconceived notion you have about oh my
god like my dicks not gonna be big
enough for I'm not gonna be able to
[__] like these porn stars do and I'm
so I'm so nervous now they don't enjoy
that [__] they don't enjoy a few of them
do but a lot of them look at their work
on set the same way you look at doing
your taxes they don't want to be doing a
[__] five-person gangbang they don't
want to they do it because it's a means
to an end for them to make a name for
themselves for them to make money it's a
job just like any other [__] job to
them shut up I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear this they love it no
lying liar here's why it's a good thing
here's why it's a good thing - oh good
because when you meet them and you
create a bond with them and they [__]
with you as a person you are able to
give them better sex than mandingo is
now imagine being able to say that like
you're Luther like when when when when
Lana tells me okay actually let me
rephrase that when al maraa tells me
because that's her actual [__] name
that I give her the best dick that she's
ever gotten in her life when she told me
that the first five times I was like are
you [__] kidding me stop being a
[__] and telling me [__] that stop
lying to me but when you start to
understand the psyche of women they are
emotionally and chemically aroused
unlike men who say oh look tits or dick
absolutely absolutely son you're
dropping [__] and so and so when you
realize that women are turned on by your
ability to connect with them relate to
them make them feel loved make them feel
chairs then you are
stand why you're able to give girls that
have had you know 20 30 whatever amount
of dicks good sex you know what I'm
saying and so really I mean dude it's
been a learning experience for me too
but I'm a wife I'm a wild dude people
asked me to try to make sense of
situations and I can't do that because
there's no sense to be made I'm just on
a rollercoaster ride that's it dude you
know you've never judged the women
though in the way that a lot of men do
and I'm a bit like you like if you could
give me a girl who's out a hundred dicks
or one dick I know which one I'm [__]
choosing a good [__] time you know
what I mean and that's why me I think
I've always liked that about you like
you don't you don't prejudge the way a
lot of people do I guess why is that why
is that for you
why do you not care if you have some
sort of religious reasoning or you have
some sort of like preconceived mindset
about the sanctity of women and what
they're supposed to be and how they're
supposed to act I completely respect
that I completely respect that there's
absolutely nothing wrong that people can
feel however they want I always say
different strokes for different folks me
personally having seen the terrors of
this [__] world having seen and by
the way done the things that I've done
who the [__] am I to judge someone for
who they've had sex with the amount bro
I hate saying this this is not me
bragging this is not me bragging the
amount of bodies I have is a hundred
times higher than the amount of Bondi
bodies that Lana Rose has quite [__]
literally bro I dude there were times in
my life where I would stick my dick in
any [__] thing dude without asking
any [__] questions I didn't give a
[__] hundreds and hundreds bro this girl
worked with 20 dudes over the course of
a year later got married and had a
husband and
only and only was having sex with him
she has maybe three or four bodies
outside of [__] porn
these are rookie numbers compared to the
bodies that I know of girls that have in
LA I understand people's inability to
get to the place that I'm talking from
because bralette is kind of [__]
nasty it's nasty [__] and unless you're
a little [__] up it won't make sense
to you for the average American the
average person in the UK who wants to
raise a family they want to do it with
this angel of a person I get that I get
that but I don't live in that world I
don't exist in that place and so so Who
am I to judge someone for for what
they've done to make ends meet it's just
not who I am it's not the kind of person
I am you know what I'm saying especially
when I've done worse so you've mentioned
LA noire a few I'm saying and the way we
watched you guys meet on camera was kind
of like cute like I remember watching it
there because obviously Laura's a
beautiful woman and as your friend I'm
like yes like I'm rooting for you all
the way you know but I never thought
that anything would come from that video
you know that birthday present video and
all of a sudden you guys clicked and I
was like yeah yeah for the camera but
this [__] was for real what was it like
when you were off-camera and you were
just being regular people how did what
made you guys connect more than you
would with another girl she's not
actually the normal the kind of girl I
would normally connect with because
what's the normal girl you'd connect
with just Justin so just in this in the
my they're usually in the mindset of
being very extroverted they want to talk
they want a party they want to do this
kind of [__] and by the way the majority
of porn stars I've had little things not
relationships I didn't date them but
I've had things with other adulterers as
you mentioned and even those ones
they're very extroverted they want a
party yeah [__] yeah drink dude whatever
right whatever the [__] they do Amara is
very different she is a true introvert
she does not want to see anyone she
wants to work on her own [__] she wants
to do her own [__] and she's very very
shy almost to a point that she's
awkwardly shy like I'm talking to her
and she doesn't really know how to
Spahn she's kind of closed off you know
um but the first thing that I noticed
about her was that she was hands down
quite literally one of the sweetest
people that I'd ever met my entire life
man like like just just so kind sweet
and just like just an a good person like
just a good person and it was apparent
to me in the first couple times that we
hung out that she was just a really nice
girl and and I it was almost like as
soon as I started hanging out with her I
hated the fact or the idea that people
judge her for what they saw and never
got the chance to know who she really
was they upset me so bad and I didn't
want to be another example of that and
so as we started to hang out and get to
know each other I realized just how
[__] great she was and how sweet and
supportive and loyal I mean since day
one every you know you guys will always
love this store of every football player
you know soccer player big dogs ro big
dogs like the homies on the big teams ro
have been in her DMS rappers big [__]
rappers I wish I could say names I'm not
gonna [__] do it
and it's always you know look who DME
and then she just deletes it deletes it
she's not she's she's very different
than everyone else in this LA Circle
mostly because you can't impress Lana
Rhodes with your Lamborghini because she
has a nicer Lamborghini than you you
know what I'm saying and so like y'all
her ability to be a businesswoman and a
crush on her own aside pushes away a lot
of that [__] where girls are usually
turned on by wealth so she's she's just
not into the same things that other
girls are she doesn't care if you have a
hit single she doesn't give a [__] if
you the only thing she cares about is
can you be loyal to her can you respect
her can you support her that's what she
cares about and so that was all very
apparent to me right off the bat and I
said y'all like dude I didn't know when
I first started talking to where I was I
within a week I was in bed with her and
Riley at the same time and I was like yo
this is gonna go the same way that this
is gone every other time I'm gonna [__]
this girl and I'm never gonna I'm gonna
and I'm gonna put her in a rotation and
I'm gonna move on to you know whoever
else and it just didn't go like that I
mean we spending we started spending
more and more time together and I think
I think I think that we see a project in
each other and I and I I don't know how
I feel about saying this but I'll just
say it I think that we both see like a
dog who's been beaten up a lot you know
what I'm saying and a dog that's you
know been put through [__] that they
wish they had in and done things that
they don't like and don't feel great
about and just want to be loved and
respected and supported when you find
someone who's willing to reciprocate
that forgiveness and that support it
goes a long way you know what I'm saying
and so it's it's uh she's been
absolutely incredible she's been
absolutely incredible and and you know
extremely supportive extry just you know
I've never had to worry about another
guy which is something to be said in LA
she all she wants to do is be with me
and all she asks his first fact and
support and you know obviously I haven't
been perfect throw you know I you know I
you know I don't know if you plan on
asking about her what haven't been
perfect yeah that was beautiful
but unfortunately I stopped listening
after you said you were in bed with
Riley and Laura at the same time what
the hell happened I need every detail
brought as much as I wish this story was
gonna be great
that threesome did not happen that
threesome didn't happen I was gonna say
she must be cuz they're like friends
they're very good yeah they're good
friend Lana's quite she seems quite
possessive over you in a good way she is
she is she
there's no we're not there's no
threesomes at all she's not she's uh
she's down for it but it would have to
be her choice it would have to be it
would have to be her choosing and
you know it also feels like to me that
uh it feels like one of those threesomes
that's actually a trap like you do it
and then your [__] you're just [__] yeah
so I probably won't do it but yeah that
that didn't happen I mean obviously you
know me and Riley had some things happen
in the past but you know it's it's a
sense that sense me and since me and I
Maura Matt dude it's you know I had
obviously that one thing that happened
but other than that it's it's been it's
just for those that don't know Mike Mike
got his dick sucked by some random girl
who really was after the clout and and
you and I you but we've both been
victims of that a little bit in the past
in different ways you got off lucky
basically that was a speed bump for you
guys and I really thought that that was
you were [__] but you handled that
both you handled that really well and
that was what made me think oh this
could last how did you how did you get
over that so fast
she didn't have that much of a leg to
stand on because we were so the
relationship was so new you know what
I'm saying like it's really hard for a
girl to meet a guy especially in LA and
for the guy to even for a second be cool
with I met you today we're dating
tomorrow it's just not how the landscape
works here or really anywhere it's like
you have this courting period you have
this talking period you have you know
then you have the exclusivity
conversation where you're like okay
you're mine I'm yours nobody else we
just strict we just hadn't gone there I
think men and women are so different
than her I guarantee if every man
watching this right now like who's had
like you know a few years or is
well-thought how many girls if I
proposed them would they have said yes
this is how many girls like the other
way would want to marry like it's
totally lopsided women are so too
relaxed about commitment I don't know
what it is men foot freak the front
scares the [__] I mean it has since day
one and so like as soon as you started
talking that way in a way that was kind
of like my like I feel like I've tried
to sabotage the relationship
where I was like yeah yo if I could just
do this maybe it'll push her away enough
that this won't happen or some [__] I
don't know what the [__] I was thinking
it was a horrible horrible mistake and
but luckily I you know I said to her
after I came back I talked to where we
hung out a bunch more times and I said
you know I made a really bad mistake I'm
really really sorry and I promise you I
looked in her eyes and I said you know I
promise you with everything in me that
this will never ever happen again I was
like I can't say that we're not gonna
break up I can't say that we're gonna
get married and have this great love
story I don't know what's gonna happen
but as long as I'm dating you you will
never have to worry about me talking to
or or having any kind of sexual
relationship with another woman
and I truly do stand by that truly mean
that and like I said like if I had that
desire and it was something I wanted I
would have a conversation about us
breaking up before I did that because
that soft bro it felt horrible it made
me upset with myself
it [__] [__] her up and it just
like if you're watching this if you're
still watching this don't [__] cheat
don't cheat dude that is that's the
worst I do believe the reason we were
able to walk past it was because we
weren't officially a relationship yet
yeah what what I want to do is give Lana
bit of credit because as an outsider
looking in especially as a youtuber like
I'm in a similar situation you saw
having a supportive relationship
especially someone who has the clout
that long hours let's not kid myself
the fact that she took that photograph I
posted your book up with her I was like
no no no not dude the next she's on the
next level bro she's a myth like
honestly she she's so [__] supportive
it's crazy she's never asked for
anything I mean I think I think you know
cuz obviously you know how the kids love
to talk bro it's been ever since she's
come around it's been a lot of reviews
and this and that like all that you know
all the [__] that obviously people deal
with when when they collaborate on the
platform it's like using this and using
that but I think I think she's I think
the crossover that we've created and
relationship has benefited the both of
us tremendously dude it's changed the
game I want to say porn stars should be
thanking her like so much because the
word porn star it's a dirty word to many
people and then all of a sudden you've
got Logan Paul one of the biggest
youtubers in the [__] world clearly
laying on the fact that he is his best
friend's girlfriend is huge on views and
he's putting there in his [__] titles
he did one today in fact right so it's
it's changing
like I guess YouTube was being seen as
this clean little kiddie thing and porn
stars being seen as this day like all of
a sudden like they're becoming
mainstream because of people like Lana
she's changing it for sure and and
listen like we're still not there all
the way and I do want to I do want a
greatly attribute and or a tribute and
and give thanks to Riley for doing it as
well because Logan's simply called Riley
and Riley made it happen Riley is a is
probably that industry's greatest gift
that they've ever been given in terms of
the ability to push the genre into an
accepted place the the gift that keeps
on giving Riley incredible she's the she
is such a great person such a good
person and you know she's obviously done
wonders for bringing it to mainstream
obviously Adam and Lana had the first
true YouTube porn relationship the
reason Adam 22 yup and Lana the plug the
reason why mine is a little bit
different and doesn't do as much of the
heavy lifting as someone else will
eventually is because she's retired
and so since she's since she's I love
the idea of thinking of myself as like
this warrior who is able to overlook
anything but I would not be able to
overlook the fact that my girlfriend was
currently doing pornography I caught it
call it a weakness in me call it I don't
know what you want to call it I can't I
would not be able to deal with that and
I think a lot of people watching this
would could understand okay
the fact that she used to do it and this
is nothing against current workers or
their ability to have relationships this
is just me for speaking for myself the
fact that she used to do it is what
makes me comfortable enough to have a
relationship with her and so yeah I mean
she's she's the best dude she's she's
incredible she's mad at me right now for
something but dude I gotta be the worst
person to [__] do cuz let cuz listen
she's a kook bro she's an introvert and
all she wants is me her maybe a couple
kids a couple Lamborghinis or really
big-ass house she doesn't even mind
paying for all of it she's basically
like you don't have to do anything just
come simp for me and I'll [__] pay
everything obviously I'm not gonna do
that but since she's such an introvert
she naturally has a problem with my
lifestyle which is the exact opposite
and so every girl that dm's me which is
a lot every girl that comments every
girl that you know I'm friends with from
the past I'm always fighting this battle
to whether or not I want to respond
because I'm a nice person who just likes
to talk to people but she looks at every
single girl that I talk to from my past
as me trying to can keep a bridge with
them so that I could [__] them down the
line do you know what I'm saying and you
know maybe she's right I'm not saying
she's right but maybe some let me just
what I'm saying is maybe her looking at
the situation like that
is right and maybe other girls who look
at the situation like that maybe that's
maybe they're right maybe maybe they do
see it as that but as far as I'm
concerned the only reason I have any
come and it's very light I don't I
rarely like any pictures anymore I
rarely do any of that but any the only
reason I'm ever talking anybody's
because yo there's a lot of girls out
there that I'm genuinely friends with
okay so can I ask you the question you
said she'd be happy settling down and a
couple of kids couple of Lamborghinis
all that good stuff
do you see that as a real serious
possibility for you guys I don't see it
as a possibility
but I don't not see it as a possibility
do you understand what I'm saying so
feel like a dream almost like it's
almost not 100% here's why and this is
the thing that we've kind of had to like
deal with this because she wants that
she really wants it she wants up
tomorrow yeah and she's 23 and I'm like
y'all trust me slow the [__] down dude
like Sheree owns houses everyone like
she's got everything all set up the
thing about me right now is and it sucks
cuz I'm 35 bro
but I am on a [__] mission right now
dude like to just to just [__] do
everything like book books gonna become
a movie then that it's it like I have a
million things going on and so like I
don't have the time unfortunately right
now to sit back count money and relax
like it's just not a luxury that I have
nor is it a luxury that I want right
this second you don't still in second
yeah like you'll just get that's it like
like once the movies done and like we
can we really can sit back and be like
y'all we've done it different story and
and and by the way also like I'm not a
believer in having those kind of
conversations six months into a
relationship absolutely like it's it's
like y'all my sister and her boyfriend
or my sister my little sister and her
current husband dated for [__] what
seven years before he bought the
question you can [__] things up by
actually rushing it like a potential
like a relation I was a real potential
letting it go and letting it grow in
that and having these wild experiences
traveling together all that if you just
settle down too quick it can almost [__]
it early continent oh yeah absolutely
and that's what I've been and that's
what and we bought dealt with a lot of
that stuff because of the kind of
pressure that she kind of puts on it
sometimes to like push the relationship
along oh they're all man they're always
doing it all of them even porn stars
oh yeah no absolutely girl girls are
infamous for bro they want to know
exactly when it starts with a toothbrush
in the bathroom
that's it starts oh yeah oh that's truth
right I don't know you might not be all
answer this because I know it's your own
relationship I wanted to know this do
you lover
yeah I do I do III mean at first I I was
um she pushed for that word so early
yeah and started using it and that word
to me it has such weight like I like my
family when I was growing up we weren't
the kind of family that just said that
like we would only say I love you if
somebody was getting on a flight or
going in for surgery you know what I'm
saying like and so did she
the fact that she kind of throws it
around a little bit more was I couldn't
relate and I wouldn't use it but
eventually when I realized the kind of
person that she was and and and and how
great she is for me and to me and and
and vice versa and the relationship that
we have and what what grew out of it I
couldn't deny it anymore and so
eventually you know it's it um like was
it was it like one of those
relationships because that was just like
crazy love at first sight it was it
really was and I can honestly say that
but what we've grown into and I like
that I like the idea that we grew into
it we were kind of like friends first
and then it kind of grew into it and so
now yeah without a shadow of a doubt I
love her I mean she's she's she's
incredible bro she's incredible I'm
happy for you mom I'm really happy for
you thank you yeah I'll watch your
little vlogs and I'm like there's Mike
I'm happy for this guy I've got a few
more questions bro
you're becoming quite a wealthy man no
money's gonna be comment to you I
wondered if you're finding yourself
becoming a little bit more materialistic
no really no not at all not not not yet
and I don't know what I don't know what
it'll start I have Adam gave me no
jumper shorts about probably a year ago
I wear them every day I have them on
right now I wear no jumper shorts every
day I have one pair of Yeezys I have a
maverick shirt that got given to me for
free I've been in LA I said it on
podcast if I wanted to get the matching
Lambo that Lana hasn't good buy right
[__] now cash
I don't I don't know I don't know what
it is I don't know why because most
business men like yourself you're a bit
of a businessman now
they are driven by that but you seem to
be driven more by the the actual game
itself rather than the outcome yeah for
sure
and also I think that the strongest
businessmen which is which is what I am
deep down understand the power of cash
on hand mm-hmm and yeah I've learned
I've learned that recently you know what
I'm saying and so like the last thing I
want to do is drive up to a meeting with
a couple of venture capital guys and I
pull up in a brand new v10 Lamborghini
and they say yo we have the next Google
if you have 500 to put up front today or
a million to put up front today you
could buy a thousand Lamborghinis in six
months or a year and me to be like oh
[__] I spent it oh I spent you know a
good chunk of my money on a [__] car
that was me a year ago just to be clear
last question for you Mike and I've
really enjoyed this mate so thanks again
for your time how would you like to be
remembered I hate I hate using this
answer because it it's it seems like
something someone who so many people
have said this but I there's nothing
that makes me feel as good as knowing
that I made a difference that I made
some sort of impact hoarding money into
a bank account buying cars having the
most views on YouTube
cuz I play in that if things go right I
could play in that 7 million viewed
apartment I have 1 3 million here
whatever it's great it's [__] amazing
dude it feels nice it doesn't feel as
nice as the message I get from some kid
that says I'm 17 I watch the impulsive
episode yesterday and I didn't go pick
up heroin today because I don't want to
go down this road any further I want to
stop and I want to make
of my [__] life and the amount of
times that I've literally like broken
down crying off of the messages people
have sent me I don't break down crying
when my publisher says yo the book sold
50,000 [__] copies in the first three
that doesn't matter to me I love that
I'm [__] happy and the reason why that
does matter is because of the message
that's in the fifth vital and so that
really makes me happy actually but when
its views are money and that kind of
[__] it doesn't satisfy me the thing
that satisfies me is knowing that
someone's life is better as a result of
me being here and so if my legacy can
only be that I made an impact on one
person or a thousand people or a hundred
thousand people were a million people
and I made their lives more livable and
made them feel okay and made them feel
happy or made them feel like they could
make something out of a shitty situation
then I've done every single [__]
thing that I was put on the planet to do
and I could go and I could rest easy bro
and the day this book went out I rested
I slept better that [__] night than I
ever have bro because I know that people
are reading it and it's making them feel
like they're gonna be okay and that is
the legacy that I want to [__] leave
and you know what it is me from the
minute our footman met you we've got on
fantastically well because my motivation
and your motivation are exactly the same
and and you feel like you're putting
together a body of work that's going to
help people over a period of time and
views are just [__] it's almost
making the differences is what it's all
about so you've definitely done that on
our credit you may I think you've got
your priorities right in life and I wish
you all the [__] success in the world
me ously priorities are right still not
perfect working out every single day and
you know who knows where that where the
journey goes where the road leads for
either of us but um you know obviously
the fifth vital on Amazon I'm sure
Geordi will get the link in there
somewhere for you absolutely yeah
and it's it's I mean listen we didn't
really talk much about the book and
we'll do it next time the process has
been crazy it's it's a really insane
process and it has been nuts to see the
feedback and how many people have opened
that book and not closed it until it was
done one sitting five hours six hours
eight hours whatever and had some sort
of life like I didn't think he was gonna
do that
I knew it was a great story but I didn't
think it was gonna do that song you're a
good writer by the way like yeah I was
impressed I was like cuz I can tell this
is you yeah I can tell it's you it's
gritty shame I appreciate that but yeah
grab the fifth light on Amazon and
that's pretty much into and I appreciate
you having me on a [__] love you dude
and I come back on whatever you want we
got to get you on impulse and I know
people want to see that yeah [__] yeah
as soon as this lockdown [__] is lifted
I'll be over limit because I need to get
over this country so don't forget to
check out the fifth vital on Amazon the
link is in the description below thumbs
are going to Mike go and check out his
channel don't forget clocked in all and
on me I'm a subscriber you got me hit
the like button subscribe to the true
Geordie YouTube channel thanks for
watching and I'll see you later